all right well let's dive in California
is on the line Justin is with us hey
Justin your question for Chris and me hi
Dave Chris thanks for having me
sure sure but the honor Tsubaki thanks
for everything you do my question is a
little different on what this is that my
dad owns the farm well actually is my
grandma's and he runs everything on it
and and my wife and I well I have a good
relationship with them but my wife just
does not get along with them and I have
my issues with him as well from being uh
I really enjoy working on the farm and
and and helping him out and he's going
through a little bit of a - entice
crisis but he he isn't really doing the
work that needs to be done on the farm
the the ranch to keep up with it and so
I try to I try to get out there and do
it and which is he doesn't pay me for
any of it which is fine I guess but I
just enjoy doing it and it's creating a
bit of an issue with me and my wife
because she doesn't I don't think she
gets the relationships one of the other
things is is we I hope to meet got it
have it passed down to me it's just what
you do for a living no no no I have a
full-time job as a consultant basically
and you can live help your dad but your
dad's being a jerk to your wife
basically yeah okay um and it's it's
just kind of like I hope to inherit it
down the road but I don't know for sure
if it if it is if I'm going to which
either way is fine with me I just enjoy
working on it and helping I would either
way I see is the family farm and my wife
and my mother convinced it warm up you
pass to me and and it I'm wasting my
time and it's are you doing the work
that Moses are you doing the work
because you think it's going to be
passed to your because you enjoy the
work uh mobile both I think it will be
but I really enjoy doing it and the fact
that first offers me that even though
it's not mine
it's not getting done yeah yeah just let
it be done here's the deal you're
telling yourself it doesn't bother you
but it does you're saying and that's
fine that's your tag that you put on and
everything because you know that's what
we want to hear and that's what you want
you want to feel like but the bottom
line is what this is called is passive
resentment and you've got passive
resentment it's going to get worse and
it's going to get worse and it's getting
worse and the only way you can fix this
is through proactive communication
somehow he's not meeting your
expectations and I think once you guys
listen if he doesn't feel like changing
that's okay
it's his farm not yours it isn't have to
change anything but at least you can get
it out in the open but right now by
they're not being any good communicate
that's the problem there's no
communication if you guys talk about
this and you get clear expectations up
on what it means to work on this and
what's free what's not free that's fine
if it's out of a spirit of generosity
that's great it's going to fuel you the
right way you're going to you're going
to feel good about that but if it's
there's any kind of hint of motive that
this is going to position me in a way
where I can inherit this then that and
you're not getting anything back in
return you're going to it's going to
foster more resentment and you're going
to be miserable as I think you're
getting this in the front end of it you
know but another way to that's really
good stuff
another way to expose what Chris was
talking about in your own emotions is
scale the discussion let's scale the
discussion let's pretend it's 20 years
from today and the farmers not left to
you and for the last 20 years you've
gone over there and kept it together and
you get the zip out of it how does that
feel pretty crappy yeah how that feels
and so when you scale it it reveals how
you really feel and by scaling in this
case I'm using the calendar so like
Chris is right I think you go sit down
with your dad and your grandparents your
grandparents on the farm right right
yeah you're gonna sit down with the I
think it I think it that it tries to
hurt to him but I don't quite understand
the oil you need to understand and you
need to understand what your part in
that is and if your part is absolutely
zero and you're not going to get
anything and you still want to go over
there and help that's fine but then
you've got another issue and that is is
that someone's not being kind to
your wife and you're continuing to
engage with them and that's
inappropriate behavior and so and you
know you're just you're playing out a
dysfunctional family script at that
point between you and your dad and so
you may just sit down talk to your
pastor about that part of it your
marriage counselor to talk about that
part of it but Chris is exactly right
you need to sit down clarify whether
you're in line for this and under what
conditions you're in line for this and
clarify what it is that you are doing
and if you're not going to get anything
at all ever do you still want to go over
there when your dad's a jerk to your
wife my answer would be no if you want
to go work on a farm go work on somebody
else's that would be mine but and if
you're not in line for this thing at all
but you know saying you have to get
something back necessarily for doing the
work but you just it's just not logical
in the process so hey man thanks for the
call but I think Chris is exactly right
you have some discussions to have with
your dad and with your grandparents and
it may reveal they may get nasty it may
reveal that this is nothing like you
thought it was and it may it may hurt
you a little bit but at least you'll
know verses 20 years later finding out
and that's how people end up not
speaking for the rest of their lives is
unmet expectations 20 years later a lot
of the stuff happens in family business
and that's what this is and in inherence
this is Chris and that's why we've
always recommended that you have a
reading of the will for all the parties
that are involved while you're still
alive those grandparents if you're the
grandparents listening and that's kind
of situation you should tell everybody
what the deal is everybody should know
so there's no confusion because if you
know you die and then they open up the
documents everybody gets confused Chris
Brown joins me this hour answering your
questions this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
down